on va revenir sur la mort de Lucas dans
les Vosges à ses obsèques la semaine
dernière il s'est suicidé harcelé au
collège parce qu'il était homosexuel
c'est pas un cas isolé Erwan
évidemment tous les enfants heureusement
ne vont pas jusqu'à commettre les
réparables coques comme Lucas mais il y
en a d'autres il y a un certain nombre
de suicides tous les ans et au-delà des
suicides le harcèlement scolaire qui
touche environ un million de d'élèves
et comment est un drame pour pour la
personne qui qui en est victime parce
que parce que souvent ça laisse des
traces irrémédiable sur sur la vie sur
surtout quasi ça ça a des conséquences
sur le niveau scolaire ça a des
conséquences sur sur un certain nombre
de choses et c'est ça qu'il faut sur
lequel il faut vraiment travailler un
million d'enfants qui sont victimes de
harcèlement scolaire ça veut dire quoi
que les moyens sont pas suffisants en
face on fait pas comme il faut je pense
que on a il y a eu une prise de
conscience depuis 10 ans une prise de
conscience qui a permis la mise en place
d'un certain nombre de politiques
publiques qui vont dans le bon sens et
ces politiques publiques d'ailleurs que
le texte de loi que nous avons voté
l'année dernière
comment dire pérenniser et amplifie mais
il faut aller encore plus loin il faut
aller encore plus loin parce qu'on a
maintenant aussi les réseaux sociaux les
réseaux sociaux ont des des conséquences
terribles parce qu'ils amplifient encore
le phénomène et ce qu'on a gagné sur le
harcèlement
[Musique]
comment scolaire traditionnel on l'a
perdu sur le sur le sur les réseaux
sociaux
invité de France Bleu Breizh Izel ce
matin
Erwan Balan vous avez porté cette loi
qui instaure un délit de harcèlement
scolaire mais le collège de Lucas il
avait le dispositif phare qui est
justement dispositif pour prévenir ce
type de harcèlement mais ça marche pas
ça marche pas si ça fonctionne parce que
on voit on voit des résultats s'améliore
mais il faut aller encore plus loin et
je pense qu'il faut amplifier la
prévention parce que dans mon texte il y
a effectivement la création du Daily
mais il y a tout ce qui va avec c'est à
dire les deux autres volets que sont
l'accompagnement et la prévention et
c'est là dessus qu'il faut mettre le
paquet prévention accompagnement et puis
il faut aussi effectivement quand c'est
nécessaire avoir des sanctions
le dispositif phare est un dispositif
jeune qu'il faut sans doute encore
améliorer il faut sans doute encore
améliorer les plans de prévention il il
faut aller plus loin et surtout moi ce
que j'aimerais c'est une prise de
conscience générale de la société une
prise de conscience qui qui se qui
ferait dire à la société qui ferait
comprendre la société que le harcèlement
scolaire c'est pas anodin c'est pas de
la sommeil en 30 ans ça a des
conséquences dramatiques des
conséquences qui peuvent aller au
suicide mais aussi je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure des conséquences sur la
scolarité sur sur le résultat de
l'ensemble d'une classe d'une école et
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il faut vraiment
vraiment combattre est-ce que vous avez
vu les choses bouger depuis votre projet
de loi
la loi elle est jeune elle a à peine un
an et vous savez un an entre la 1 an
avec une prise effective en septembre à
la rentrée voyez bien que que c'est tout
c'est tout jeune mais ça c'est aussi le
rôle d'un parlementaire moi je vais
continuer à suivre ce projet avec
beaucoup d'attention et voter des lois
c'est une étape mais maintenant ce qu'il
faut et c'est ça le l'enjeu aujourd'hui
je crois je crois qu'on a l'appareil
nécessaire maintenant on a ce qu'il faut
et maintenant il va falloir mettre les
moyens il va faire les mettre les moyens
et massifier ses moyens dans toutes les
écoles de notre pays et pour que pour
que pour que ce genre de RAM ne se
reproduisent pas et que pour que chaque
enfant de notre République est confiance
en l'école parce que perdre la confiance
en l'école c'est perdre la confiance
dans notre société et ça fait des
individus des personnalités qui qui
auront toute leur vie sans doute des
problèmes à
s'épanouir dans dans cette dans cette
société dans notre pays merci Erwan
balade on est tranquille
ce matin député MoDem du fin